chers collègues
[Musique]
chers collègues s'il vous plaît
nous allons commencer la deuxième
audition de l'après-midi
et nous entendons cet après-midi
Monsieur Jean-François delfresci que
nous revoyons dans des sujets sur des
sujets un peu différents de ceux qui
nous ont occupés depuis deux ans mon
président du Comité consultatif national
d'éthique pour la présentation de la vie
publiée le 13 septembre dernier sur les
questions éthiques relatives aux
situations de fin de vie sont également
présents les deux rapporteurs de la vie
ça leur effet Monsieur Régis Aubry et
Alain Cleis jeune dit que cette audition
fait l'objet d'une captation vidéo qui
sera retransmise en direct sur le site
du Sénat est disponible en vidéo à la
demande
cet avis fait suite à une auto cesine du
CCNE et à vocation selon ses propres
termes à éclairer le débat citoyen les
pratiques des professionnels de santé et
le législateur il considère de façon
inédite je cite qu'il existe une voix
pour une application éthique de l'aide
active à mourir dans le même temps la
vie relève deux insuffisances celle du
développement des soins palliatifs dans
notre pays bien documenté dans un récent
rapport de notre commission et celle de
la connaissance et de la mise en oeuvre
de la loi du 2 février 2016 dite loi
classe léonique
partageant ce constat mais en tirant une
conclusion différente du membre du CCN
ont souhaité publier une réserve
considérant ce site
que franchir
ce pas législatif sans ces efforts
préalables représentaient un
représenterait un risque de renoncement
que nous ne souhaitons pas prendre le 13
septembre dernier le président de la
République a annoncé le lancement d'une
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
dans le pilotage a été confié au Conseil
économique social et environnemental et
que la première ministre a saisi de
l'interrogation suivante le cadre
d'accompagnement de la fin de vie a-t-il
adapté aux différentes situations
rencontrées ou d'éventuelles changements
devraient être introduit les conclusions
de la convention sont attendues pour la
fin mars 2023 dans cette attente
messieurs pourriez-vous nous exposer
quel serait cette voie pour une
application éthique de l'aide actif
amoureux et en quoi le cadre législatif
actuel devrait être modifié le cas
échéant pour ouvrir cette voie monsieur
le Président vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames et Messieurs les sédataires
c'est l'actrice
donc je vous voyiez aujourd'hui comme
président du CCNE et oublions que vous
m'avez interpellé à plusieurs reprises
dans le cadre du covid
alors
peut-être un rappel sur et je laisserai
la parole ensuite aux deux rapports sur
les conditions dans lequel a été
construit la vie 139
je rappelle son titre parce qu'il est
important question éthique
relative aux situations de la fin de vie
autonomie et solidarité
en juin 2021 alors qu'on était encore en
situation de sinon de crise sanitaire en
tout cas de ou la question se posait
encore j'ai souhaité que le CCNE s'auto
saisis de ce sujet compte tenu d'un
certain nombre de démarches
parlementaires que nous avions vu dans
le premier semestre 2021 pour
éventuellement aller vers une
modification de la loi-classe et Unity
il m'apparaissait important que le CCNE
s'auto saisissent ce sujet
indépendamment d'une commande qui aurait
pu être une commande politique
il y a donc eu comme la construction de
ce font les avis du CCNE avec un groupe
de travail les trois rapporteurs qui a
commencé à travailler des délétés qui a
auditionné
plus de 40 personnes ou groupes
représentations
et ensuite on s'est trouvé à la fin de
l'année 2021 avec une situation pas
inédite mais voilà qui tombait au milieu
de la vie avec un changement des membres
du CCNE
d'une partie des membres du CCNE et donc
on avait déjà commencé à travailler la
ville le groupe de travail avait déjà
présenté ses premières visions sa
première vision au CCN plaignait puisque
je vous rappelle que dans la
fonctionnement de notre instance toutes
les décisions sont prises au niveau du
CCN plaignait même si elles sont guidées
par les recommandations d'un groupe de
travail
et donc voilà il y a eu du retard comme
souvent dans les dans les nominations
dans ces dans ces instances et donc nous
avons continué à travailler puis le
nouveau comité est arrivé évidemment on
est reparti de zéro pas mais il a fallu
qu'il s'en partent entre guillemets du
sujet donc il s'est emparé du sujet le
groupe de travail à ce moment-là c'est
passé directement sur le mode du travail
du plénier complet et cet avis a été
voté à une très large majorité fin juin
à ce moment là depuis le début et c'est
normal sur un sujet de ce type
il est il existait une partie des
membres du groupe de travail et certains
également au niveau du comité plénier
qui avait qui portait un avis nuancé
minoritaire sur les recommandations qui
peuvent être faites et c'est très simple
c'est très très simple que sur un sujet
aussi difficile aussi complexe et c'est
le propre même du CCNE nous puissions
avoir des avis minoritaires le groupe
minoritaire a souhaité fin juin au
moment où nous avons voté cet avis
reréfléchir sur les conditions dans
lequel il souhaitait présenter son avis
minoritaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle je n'ai pas présenté cet avis
de façon publique début juillet comme je
l'avais prévu mais j'ai attendu que le
groupe minoritaire me redonne le texte
qui lui convenait sous le forme d'une
réserve entre guillemets
qui m'a été donné dans le courant du
mois d'août et nous avons rediscuté lors
du premier planning de septembre et
finalement cet avis a donc été rendu en
tenant compte et en incluant dans la vie
cette réserve pour le début septembre si
je passe un peu de temps sur ce qui est
très chronologique et qui ne peut le
fond de la vie c'est pour que les choses
soient claires pour tout le monde qui ne
le CCNE est une instance d'intelligence
collective c'est une instance qui doit
tenir compte surtout sur des sujets
difficiles de ce type
d'avis choix minoritaire soit soit
différent c'est ce que nous avons fait
sur le fond la très large majorité du
CCNE a voté cet avis et la réserve et a
été votée par huit membres sur les 45
membres actuels du CCN donc voilà sur
sur les sur les points alors ensuite sur
la ville lui-même
il comprend en fait trois parties et je
laisserai les rapporteurs dissertés un
peu sur ces trois parties la première
c'est le rappel de tout ce qui a déjà
été inscrit
je dirais discuter fait l'objet d'avis
de de comité divers et variés sur la fin
de vie au cours des
15-20 dernières années et en particulier
au sein du CCNE lui-même qui a déjà pris
un certain nombre de réflexions et de
position
la deuxième partie de cette première
partie elle est sur finalement le bilan
de la loi Claisse Leonetti
est-ce que cette loi est suffisamment
connue est-ce qu'elle est suffisamment
appliquée la réponse est à chaque fois
non pas suffisamment à la fois par le
grand public les professionnels compris
les professionnels de santé avec des
disparités régionales et puis un bilan
que vous partagez que vous avez écrit
également sur le fait que la politique
de soins palliatifs menée en France
depuis de nombreuses années n'est pas à
la hauteur d'un grand pays comme le
nôtre et qu'il y a encore des trous dans
la raquette sur un certain nombre de
départements où il n'existe pas encore
de services de soins palliatifs ou on a
mis les soins palliatifs dans une
position un peu dans un corner au sein
de la structure hospitalière ils sont à
la fois à l'hôpital mais ils sont pas
tout à fait dans l'hôpital et puis
surtout il y a des grandes lacunes en
termes de soins palliatifs par exemple
dans les EHPAD et surtout encore sur les
soins palliatifs à domicile qui pour des
raisons diverses et variées n'ont été
très peu développés en France donc ça
c'est c'est la première pratique qui est
une forme de constat la deuxième partie
est sur laquelle vous aurez plus à nous
interroger et sur finalement mais même
si on a l'ensemble des moyens que nous
souhaitons sur les soins palliatifs sur
ce que je viens d'indiquer y a-t-il un
certain nombre de situations que
auxquelles la loi Claisse néonetti ne
répond pas totalement
et c'est là où en effet on a posé un
certain nombre de situations en
particulier pour des personnes pour des
patients et atteints de maladies
chroniques dégénératives
neurodégénérative en particulier ou
atteints de maladie incurables mais non
pas à court terme puisque la loi classe
néonetti permet de résoudre les
problèmes à court terme mais dans le
moyen terme ce qu'on appelait dans le
moyen terme c'est quelques semaines à
quelques mois et là où un certain nombre
de situations où la loi questionnait-il
ne répond pas totalement la question et
là en effet on va vous préciser dans
quelles conditions éthique une porte
pour être entre bâillé sur une vision
nouvelle de ce qui pourrait être une
aide à une mort dans la dignité et puis
enfin dans la troisième partie et elle
est à mes yeux aussi très importante
parce que c'est le rôle du CCNE d'être
garant que
sur un sujet aussi difficile
sur un sujet où on voit bien on touche
au fond même de l'humanité on touche sur
des questions
individuelles très fortes très sensible
et bien on puisse laisser s'exprimer
bien sûr
ce qui sera peut-être un vote des
parlementaires et des sénateurs mais
qu'avant cette période il puisse y avoir
un grand débat national qui puisse
s'ouvrir sur ce sujet et on a maintenant
et on sait on a on sait mieux mené en
France ce type de grand débat national
donc on a recommandé en effet le
président de la République dans son
communiqué nous a suivi ces trois
parties du débat national qui vont
porter à la fois sur ce que va porter le
CESU avec finalement une convention
citoyenne ce qui sera porté par le CCNE
et les espaces éthiques régionaux dans
les territoires comme on l'avait fait
lors des états généraux de la bioéthique
avec des réunions d'information pour les
citoyens qui perdu dans la terminologie
dans un certain nombre de questions et
qui pourront à juste titre poser des
questions à des experts dans un climat
de neutralité même sur du débat on en a
bien compte on se rend bien compte et
puis une troisième partie qui sera menée
plutôt par le Centre national de fin de
soins palliatifs et de fin de vie sur ce
problème très difficile de comment
finalement on a médicalisé la mort dans
ce pays depuis de nombreuses années 90%
des décès surviennent à l'hôpital c'est
une fonction qui n'était pas forcément
celle des médecins bien sûr de s'occuper
des patients les plus fragiles mais
s'occuper de l'ensemble je dirais de la
mortalité c'est une vraie question pour
pour un médecin et donc d'écouter des
équipes soignantes soit spécialisées
dans les soins palliatifs
soit
non spécialisé mais qui a différents
titres sont impliqués on voit bien là
les cancérologues on voit là les
certains certains services de neurologie
certains services de réanimation et ce
cette prise en compte je dirais de
l'ensemble des équipes soignantes et pas
seulement des médecins parce que sur la
fin de vie les aides-soignantes ont
autant d'importance largement qu'un
médecin et bien sur ces points là il est
essentiel d'écouter les équipes même si
elles partent plutôt actuellement avec
un regard plutôt critique entre
guillemets sur le sujet mais ça pose
finalement la question essentielle et je
terminerai là-dessus est-ce que notre
mort nous appartient ou est-ce qu'elle
appartient à la société qui la délégué
au médecin et cette question
fondamentale au plan éthique est mise
maintenant sur la table
très bien alors messieurs les
rapporteurs qui commencent
le président
je suis heureux de me retrouver
au Sénat dans une autre vie
lorsqu'il y a eu à discuter de cette
couette 2016 j'étais venu au Sénat en
débattre les gens gardent j'en garde un
très bon souvenir et en plus lors de la
commission mixte paritaire non s'il a
pas dû trouver entre les deux assemblées
un accord
avec Régis et sous la présidence de
Jean-François d'être Francis nous avons
travaillé avec un groupe de travail ce
sujet et je commencerai par les mots de
conclusion de président
ce qu'il disait pose le sujet d'un
équilibre entre
solidarité
de la société les avis de ses citoyens
et l'autonomie de la personne
alors pourquoi nous avons décidé de nous
auto saisir
il y a un an et demi
peut-être pour trois raisons
la première raison
il y avait un débat fort
dans l'opinion sur ce sujet je ne parle
pas des sondages qui pour moi n'ont pas
grande importance sur un quel sujet
il y a eu des initiatives parlementaires
et puis il y a eu un contexte
aussi important
la situation
des soignants dans les hôpitaux
dans les structures médicales des EHPAD
où il y avait un mal-être et le message
qui était passé était
[Musique]
résumé nous avons pas les moyens pas
forcément financiers mais les moyens de
prendre en charge correctement les
patients et puis il y a eu cette période
du covid
vous êtes des élus vous savez les drames
qui se sont passés
dans les EHPAD non pas
du fait de l'épidémie même parce que les
mesures étaient prises mais toutes les
conséquences
auprès des familles auprès des personnes
les pavillons pas pu faire leur deuil
bref un climat extrêmement long je crois
qu'on ne peut pas aborder ce sujet sans
avoir tout cela dans la tête c'est ce
qu'on a essayé moi je sais que en tant
que sénatrice et sénateurs vous avez à
travers vos territoires tout cela en
tête
et puis
il sait pas rien passé depuis 20 ans
depuis 20 ans
le Sénat et l'Assemblée des
parlementaires
ont toujours travaillé
pour tenir les deux bouts de la chaîne
solidarité autonomie soyez avec les lois
de 1999 sur des soins palliatifs
je fais une parenthèse mais à titre
individuel j'espère que le président ne
fâchera pas je crois qu'il fera changer
de nom un jour
faudra peut-être plus parler de soin
d'accompagnement parce que soin
palliatifs c'est quand il y a plus rien
à faire c'est ressenti comme ça comme le
rappeler le président et c'est pas des
petites choses dans beaucoup d'hôpitaux
c'est ailleurs
je crois que tes soins d'accompagnement
c'est des soins c'est véritablement
l'institution dans notre pays d'une
politique de santé de la personne
de la personne et on développe ce sujet
sur lequel lequel régisse va venir donc
99 c'était quand même de la part de la
nation une volonté de solidarité il y a
eu 2002 la loi Coster
la loi kouchtner qui
renforge j'allais dire le pouvoir des
patients pouvoir arrêter un traitement
c'est pas rien
prêt bien sûr un débat avec l'équipe
soignante il y a eu la loi de Jean
Léonetti en 2005 qui était l'obstination
déraisonnable
j'attire votre attention
c'est un sujet qui va revenir
d'actualité dans les jours qui viennent
je crois que c'est autour du vin 20
octobre à novembre il y a une QPC aux
conseils constitutionnel
où ce sujet va être traité je sais pas
si vous avez suivi cela d'un côté des
médecins l'équipe soignante qui
considèrent que prolonger la vie à la
personne et une obstination
déraisonnable et de l'autre la famille
ou une partie de la famille qui
considère que à travers des directives
anticipées ce qu'il faut vérifier la
personne quelle que soit la situation ne
souhaitait pas interruption de la vie
donc c'est
à dire la confrontation
de jaillir de loin de droit et donc
c'est un sujet important et enfin la loi
de 2016 auquel j'ai pu participer et aux
quelques années au Sénat amender et
adopter c'est trois nouveaux droits
directives anticipées au pesables la
personne de confiance et la sédation
profonde et continue jusqu'au décès donc
on voit bien à travers ce Corps
législatif qui est un cadre il y a cet
équilibre entre solidarité et autonomie
et je crois que les trois questions
auxquelles nous a eu nous ont eu à
répondre
sont relativement simple
première question c'est
est-ce que ces lois sont correctement
appliquées sur l'ensemble du territoire
est-ce qu'il y a des inégalités
territoriales ou sociales
dans l'application de ces lois
nous répondons clairement oui
des soins palliatifs vous avez fait un
rapport le Sénat un rapport très très
fouillé voilà on en mesure que ça soit
les limites géographiques
certains départements ne disposent pas
de soins palliatifs on en mesure en
termes de formation de recherche
et de nombre de paysph en soins
palliatifs je crois que à ma
connaissance il y a pas un laboratoire
une cerne
sur la recherche sur les champs
palliatifs et il existe pas je crois de
Pipa actuellement dans le pays sur ces
soins là donc on voit bien qu'il y a
cette inégalité et puis je parlais
accompagnement pour substituer ce mot
sur un palliatif il y a c'est aussi
volonté de des familles de mobilité
c'est à dire ne pas terminer sa vie à
l'hôpital et c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
quand on regarde la situation dans les
EHPAD ou à domicile il y a beaucoup de
retard sur les soins palliatifs c'est la
première chose la première question à
laquelle on devait s'interroger et la
deuxième question c'est sur la loi de
2016 il y a pas d'évaluation il y a pas
d'évaluation de cette loi mais moi je
vous cite qu'un exemple le CHU de
Poitiers que je connais un peu moins mal
la directrice générale a recruté une
infirmière qui est passée par la
cancérologie soit palliatif ou
et EHPAD pour populariser ce que sont
les directives anticipées
popularisés auprès des patients mais
aussi auprès du corps auprès du corps
médical sera sédation profondé continue
là encore il y a il y a des
insuffisances ou parfois des
méconnaissance
puis d'autres questions
qui donc sur la loi de 2016 je sais pas
ce qui a décidé le Sénat je crois savoir
que l'assemblée a décidé d'une
évaluation
voilà bon ça c'est au Parlement c'est à
vous de voir quels seront les
évaluations
qui sont réalisées et la troisième
question
qui ne doit pas être dissociée des deux
autres j'y insiste réduire la vie du
CCNE à l'aide active à mourir ça serait
un contresens et je pense que ce serait
quelque chose qui pourrait fausser
totalement le débat
la question on a voulu se poser est-ce
qu'il y a des situations
particulières exceptionnelles ou y
compris la loi de 2016 ne répond pas
et où on peut légitimement s'interroger
y compris dans des situations les sons
palliatifs sont présents là on touche au
cœur de
comment dans une un lieu où la
solidarité joue l'autonomie peut exister
parce que nous on pense et je parle de
sous contrôle de Régis et de
Jean-François
il ne peut pas y avoir d'autonomie sans
solidarité
car si on considère cela ça veut dire
que notre société décide de laisser aux
personnes seules la prise en compte de
la mort une société qui fonctionne comme
ça et à mon sens
inacceptable pour les uns et les autres
et donc le sujet de l'autonomie
a essayé on l'aborder
non pas en demandant de réforme mais on
s'est dit la question que l'on s'est
posée s'il législateur
décidait d'aller dans cette direction
comment devons-nous aborder ce sujet
est-ce qu'il est éthique de l'aborder
par rapport au CCN par rapport aux avis
que le cessionnaire avait formulé
précédemment et deuxièmement quelqu'un
il est nécessaire de mettre en place
pour
encadrer cette éventuel
c'était habituelle avancée voilà le
travail que nous avons fait et je
reviens pas sur la dernière partie de
des recommandations
c'est pas notre rôle de dire qu'un
référendum n'est pas adapté un tel sujet
mais nous l'avons dit quand même
parce que je crois que la situation est
tellement complexe que c'est qu'un
vraiment la démocratie représentative
d'aborder ce sujet après une conférence
citoyenne mais Régis va détailler des
mesures sur lesquelles nous avons
travaillé merci
merci Monsieur Aubry
merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames messieurs d'être attentif à ces
questions
complexes comme toujours quand on parle
de questions de fin de vie ce n'est
jamais simple ce qui rend les choses
compliquées c'est qu'on aucun d'entre
nous ne peut avoir l'expérience de la
fin de vie personne n'en est revenu
donc on est forcément en questionnement
par rapport à quelque chose dont on ne
peut pas avoir d'expérience et les
expériences dont on se souvient sont en
général pas les expériences très
qui laisse des souvenirs autre que
douloureux l'expérience de proche qui
pourquoi il est difficile à mon avis de
débattre est-ce que nous avons essayé de
faire pendant plus d'un an au sein du
CCNE c'est de prendre un peu de distance
par rapport à nos propres expériences de
nature personnelle
je parvenir sur ce qui a été dit parce
que
je pense qu'il faut qu'on laisse une
large place à vos questions mais je
voudrais peut-être pointer de 3
spécificités qui ont motivé quand même
notre
auto saisine je parle aussi alors
évidemment en tant que membre du comité
consultatif c'est un éthique mais je
suis aussi médecin pour sûr de médecine
palliative engagé depuis dans ce domaine
depuis assez longtemps
bon j'avoue que je trouve que nous ne
pouvons pas et nous ne devons pas
ignorer un changement de paradigme très
conséquent dans le champ de la médecine
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus qu'hier on est confronté à
des situations impensées de fin de vie
et
cette pensée c'est parfois la médecine
qui le génère
c'est le corollaire du progrès
de la médecine dont on va pas discuter
heureusement d'ailleurs sauf être
révisionniste à mon sens mais le corps à
l'air du progrès
et y compris malgré le développement
dont on redira qu'il est insuffisant et
je reviendrai brièvement mais le
corollaire de ce progrès c'est que
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés à des
situations que Jean-François Delfraissy
nommait
personne qui sont confrontées à des
maladies chronicisées
avec une incurabilité de leur maladie
donc c'est comme si on avait un peu
allongé le temps de la fin de
l'existence et de la confrontation avec
la question de sa propre finitude
ça touche tous les âges
on a une transformation de certains
cancers en maladie chronique par exemple
on est en train de d'augmenter
l'espérance de vie de certaines maladies
neurodégénératives
mais une conséquence aussi qu'on voit
régulièrement c'est elle est liée au
vieillissement qui lui-même est lié à
ses avancées techniques et scientifiques
on a le plus en plus de personnes qui
vivent de plus en plus longtemps avec
quelque chose qui était une forme
d'impensée une politique pathologiste
ils sont plus atteintes plusieurs
maladies synchrones
les questions qu'on doit se poser elles
sont de deux ordres
ou 3 ans
le premier ordre de question c'est
comment faire pour que la médecine ne
fabrique pas des situations
insensées elle le peut nous le disons
dans cet avis nous l'avions dit dans un
avis précédent
ça n'est pas parce que l'on sait faire
que l'on doit faire en médecine qu'en
faire conduire à faire souffrir
le deuxième axe qu'il faut aborder pour
essayer de
d'éclairer ces questions là c'est de se
dire est-ce que les différents plans de
développement des soins palliatifs dont
un est encore en cours
suffisent ou pas et ce sur quoi nous
insistons beaucoup dans cet avis je vais
pas revenir sur ce qu'a dit
Jean-François delfresci mais j'insiste
sur une notion qui est la nécessité
aujourd'hui compte tenu de ce que je
viens de vous dire de développer et
d'avoir pour tous les professionnels de
santé une culture palliative intégrée à
leurs pratiques professionnelles ça
apparaît extrêmement important de mon
point de vue ça appelle
la nécessité d'actionner un levier c'est
celui de la formation et celui de la
recherche
et ces deux leviers sont insuffisamment
mobiliser aujourd'hui on ne forme pas
les gens suffisamment à la question de
la réflexion sur la finitude de l'homme
les humanités médicales ont en partie
disparue on ne forme pas assez les
personnes à la réflexion éthique est une
réflexion compliquée
interprofessionnelle qui nécessite
d'apprendre à débattre
à ne pas être sûr de soi ou pas trop sûr
de soi
mais il n'en reste pas moins vrai que au
terme de cette réflexion et quand bien
même nous aurions un développement de la
culture palliative intégrée aux soins
palliatifs avec une universitarisation
effective
de ces questions un développement de la
recherche il n'en reste pas moins vrai
que nous sommes et nous serons
confrontés à des situations alors qu'on
peut qualifier de rares ou
d'exceptionnel mais de personnes qui
avant la toute fin de leur vie donc
avant le champ dans lequel s'applique la
loi actuelle laisse Leonetti je parle en
particulier de la question de la
sédation profonde et continue on est
confronté à des personnes qui
dont l'existence
n'est plus que souffrance
ce sont des personnes qui font des
demandes d'aide actives à mourir ce sont
des personnes celles dont nous parlons
là qui bien entendu doivent avoir
bénéficié de soins palliatifs enfin on
imagine mal que ça soit optionnel
et nous avons beaucoup réfléchi à cette
notion d'être active à mourir et on
distingue je me permets d'insister parce
que la nuance est majeure pour nous on
distingue dans ses aides actives à
mourir on distingue bien la question de
l'assistance au suicide de celle de
l'euthanasie
peut-être pour
l'assistance au suicide consiste à
permettre une personne d'avoir accès à
un produit létal qu'elle se délivre ou
qu'elle absorbe elle-même
j'attire votre attention que
dans certains états des États-Unis comme
l'État d'Oregon que nous avons
particulièrement regardé
on voit bien qu'un nombre important de
personnes qui ont demandé l'aide
d'active à mourir et donc l'accès à
l'assistance aux suicide ne vont pas
chercher le produit létal et parmi
celles qui vont le chercher ce produit
l'état d'un certain nombre ne l'absorbe
pas ça n'est pas parce que l'on fait une
demande que l'on va au bout de cette
demande à la différence de l'euthanasie
ou finalement si vous répondez à la
demande par un acte qui est administré
l'administration d'un produit little par
un tiers c'est évidemment son retour
vous voyez cette nuance elle est de
notre point de vue fondamental en ce
sens que pour reprendre ce que disait à
la classe nous essayons de travailler
sur
cette notion de respect de l'autonomie
de la personne tout autant que sur ce
devoir de solidarité que nous avons
vis-à-vis des personnes en situation de
grande souffrance et de grandes
vulnérabilité nous insistons beaucoup
dans cet avis en plus sur le fait alors
là-dessus à la lumière de quelques
travaux de recherche qui viennent d'être
publiés nous avons auditionné les
chercheurs ou les équipes de recherche
qui ont travaillé là-dessus
nous insistons beaucoup sur
le fait qu'une demande ne signifie pas
une volonté
demande avant qu'elle ne soit
l'expression de la volonté doit être
tout à fait analysée il y a beaucoup de
demandes qui traduisent autre chose que
la volonté de mourir mais l'épuisement
de la vie les plus la souffrance etc
donc c'est c'est demande doivent faire
l'objet d'une analyse on imagine mal
quand bien même la loi évoluerait que
l'on accepte comme ça parce que c'est
demandé à
la possibilité de
l'assistance au suicide il faut que
cette analyse soit fine il faut que la
demande soit réitérer qu'elle soit ferme
et que la demande et la volonté soit
confirmée par un collectif et pas
simplement par une personne
donc nous en sommes arrivés à faire
cette distinction qui peut apparaître
spécieuse à certains mais qui ne nous
apparaissent surtout pas entre de formes
d'aide active à Maurice l'assistance aux
suicide et la question de l'euthanasie
pour les raisons que je viens de vous
développer auquel on peut naturellement
répondre
si vous vous interrogez sur ce point
c'est le segment sur lequel nous pensons
qu'effectivement il pourrait
être éthique de faire évoluer le droit
dans cette direction il nous semble
qu'il pourrait y avoir pour répondre
par solidarité et par respect de
l'autonomie de la personne à certaines
situations qui donnent mon point de vue
et de mon expérience il se trouve que je
travaille sur ces situations en tant que
chercheur sont très très rares si on y
fait bien attention mais la rareté ne
doit pas nous empêcher de réfléchir à
cette réalité
donc nous sommes arrivés à
cette idée qu'il nous faut
à la fois imaginer un développement
d'une politique d'accompagnement des
vulnérabilités que ça soit le
vieillissement ou les soins pallatifs
qui soient à la hauteur des réalités que
nous connaissons des besoins qui ne sont
pas couverts en matière de culture
palliative
et c'est ce qui nous différencie
d'ailleurs du huit personnes qui ont
souhaité qu'il y a une alerte nous
pensons majoritairement que c'est et
nous ne pouvons pas conditionner
conditionner la réflexion sur une
évolution du droit à au développement
qui serait évalué à des soins créatifs
bien sûr que nous le demandons il y
aurait rien de pire que de loi
qui ne s'accompagnerait pas d'une
politique d'une loi autorisant
l'aide active à mourir et si de notre
point de vue plutôt la question de
l'assistance au suicide et qui ne serait
pas accompagné d'une vraie politique
d'accompagnement des situations de
vulnérabilité ça serait à mon avis un
peu catastrophique
et puis Jean-François delfresci il a dit
et je termine là-dessus ce qui nous
apparaît important c'est que
ces nuances dont nous essayons de vous
parler toutes ces
toutes ces nuances nous apparaissent
essentielles à connaître de tous nous
avons une fâcheuse tendance à vouloir
simplifier ce qui est complexe et en
l'occurrence je prends qu'il ne faut
qu'il ne le faut pas et donc c'est un
peu sur ce point que nous insistons sur
l'intérêt du débat public parce que à
mon avis ces questions cette complexité
elle doit être explicite ça nous
apparaît fondamental et c'est sur cette
base d'une complexité assumée de nuances
qui apparaissent comme essentielle que
nous pouvons de notre point de vue
envisager une évolution éthique autour à
la fois les politiques et du droit
merci merci beaucoup donc plusieurs
collègues inscrits Corinne Imbert qui
avait été co-rapporteur de la mission
sur les soins palliatifs merci mais la
présidente merci monsieur le Président
merci chers collègue pour vos propos et
la présentation sera de cet avis
sur tout d'abord monsieur le Président
vous l'avez rappelé sur le bilan de la
loi classe Leonetti c'est un bilan
partagé avec le Sénat et notamment avec
ce qui est exprimé dans dans le rapport
de la mission d'information sur les
soins palliatifs que j'avais eu
l'honneur de conduire avec mes deux
collègues christine bofandidosa et
Michel meunier qui sont ici présentes
néanmoins 6 ans seulement j'allais dire
alors le temps il court le temps est
long tout est relatif évidemment
notamment quand on parle de fin de vie
mais si en ce sont écoulées depuis la
dernière intervention du législateur
donc depuis 2016 la situation a-t-elle à
ce point changé que le comité
consultatif nationality qui estimait en
2013 qui n'était pas souhaitable de lui
de légaliser l'assistance au speed
puisse juger possible légiférer à
présent dans ce sens et la vie estime en
effet qu'il existe une voix pour une
application éthique de la dactive à
mourir selon les termes employés et
le rapport si des phénomènes assez
hétérogènes pour justifier l'existence
de cette voie en faisant référence à tes
éléments objectifs et c'est ce que le
professeur régisse
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est à dire les
situations limites que constitue une
nouvelle forme de fin avec la
médiathèque médicalisation et donc c'est
allongement de la fin de vie et puis des
éléments subjectifs notamment
l'extension de situation de solitude une
demande croissante d'autonomie psychique
etc
et ce que je voudrais savoir si peut-on
quantifier ou circonscrire plus
précisément les situations objectives
le sujet ne revêt-il pas au fond une
démission une dimension plus subjective
comme objectif dans le sens où il
procède moins de la prise en compte de
la situation des personnes qui vont
mourir que de celles qui veulent mourir
moins de la fin de vie apprebandit que
du suicide
l'un des arguments les plus persuasifs
pour légiférant en matière d'être active
à mourir serais-je mais bien le
conditionnel serait celui selon lequel
il s'agit d'une demande claire de la
société et vous l'avez évoqué je pense
qu'il faudrait exactement savoir l'état
de l'opinion en la matière et d'où
l'importance d'une consultation parce
qu'on voit bien que certains sondages un
petit peu plus subtils font à part une
préférence pour les soins palliatifs
plutôt que pour l'aide active à mourir
et et plutôt que que l'euthanasie mais
on parle bien ici vous avez bien fait de
le rappeler sur de l'aide active à
mourir et vous le savez encore mieux que
moi ou en tout cas au moins autant
la volonté des individus peut changer or
quand la loi est votée la loi est votée
pour tous donc et souvent la volonté des
individus qui peut changer les
professionnels de santé nous le disent
on l'a entendu quand on a conduit cette
mission des personnes qui arrivent dans
une structure de palliatifs qui voulait
mourir et puis qu'une fois qu'ils sont
accompagnés
et très importante effectivement et bien
veulent un peu plus de temps à vivre
donc c'est pour ça que tout ça est
important
de questions remarques ne doit pas ne
doit-on pas craindre que la modification
de la loi pour autoriser l'aide à qui va
mourir ne servent de prétexte pour ne
pas développer les soins palliatifs
donc tout s'accorde à reconnaître
l'insuffisance sur notre territoire et
c'est ce que nous avions pointé
également évidemment et je crois que
vous le partagez dans notre rapport et
enfin une une dernière question que
pensez-vous de l'évolution de
l'expression mourir dans la dignité à
laquelle certains préfèrent aujourd'hui
l'expression mourir dans la liberté je
vous remercie
on va prendre toutes les questions voilà
Bernard Chaumier ensuite Olivier Hainaut
et Daniel merci
madame la Présidente merci à vous trois
pour votre vos exposés au
moi quand je lis votre rapport j'étais
perplexe je vous posez quelques
questions et j'ai trouvé vos
explications orales plus convaincantes
en fait ce qui montre bien la difficulté
de parler du sujet c'est à dire que il
fait quand même pu que 80 pages je sais
plus donc beaucoup de choses à écrire 63
pardon
mais
je trouve que les choses ont été mieux
exprimées oralement par vous-même et
avec cette question quand même
fondamentale puisque c'est un rapport du
CCNE c'est pas un rapport politique
cette question du principe d'autonomie
qu'on a vu croître et au fil des lois de
bioéthiques c'est un principe c'est une
valeur qui a grandi qui a de plus en
plus infusé
nos lois de bioéthiques et là on se pose
la question de la limite de ce principe
que Jean-François delfrecy illustré
parfaitement à la fin de son propos en
disant la question c'est est-ce que ma
mort m'appartient donc c'est une
question je crois qui nous interroge
tous et moi à laquelle je trouve la
réponse très difficile à apporter parce
que certes ce principe a pris une place
centrale et qui faut lui reconnaissent
et c'est une demande de la société mais
il ne peut pas ne pas être confronté au
principe d'intérêt général et pas
uniquement au principe de solidarité
d'ailleurs il doit être confronté à
d'autres principes que le principe de
solidarité donc ça c'est une première
question alors évidemment vous n'êtes
pas allé au bout dans votre rapport mais
pour pour le législateur je crois que on
ne peut pas trancher cette question
d'une nouvelle loi si on ne tranche pas
notre rapport les limites composent au
principe d'autonomie deuxièmement vous
posez dans votre recommandation à la fin
de votre apport vous avez des termes
très forts vous posez des conditions
strictes auxquelles il serait
inacceptable de transiger en cas de
législation sur l'aide active à mourir
c'est à dire en terme de langage que
tout le monde comprend des lignes rouges
et quand au niveau de ligne rouge c'est
à peu près c'est essentiellement sur un
réel accès aux soins palliatifs aux
soins bon d'accompagnement pour
l'ensemble des Français très bien qui
croit au cours de cette table que à
échéance de deux ans trois ans ou 5 ans
vous avez rappelé monsieur Aubry les
problèmes de forme et qui sont de
formation notamment tous les Français
auront accès à ces soins moi je crois
pas un mot je suis pas là depuis très
longtemps 5 ans mais je veux dire les
les plans sont un palliatifs on les
enchaîne les assurances ministérielles
on en fait des colliers entiers et en
réalité c'est que la situation elle
évolue je dis pas mais franchement un
rythme qui nous met très très loin
l'objectif donc moi j'ai lu votre avis
en bossien comme
à l'inverse de ce qui en est sorti dans
le débat publics les bas publics c'est
le CCNE ouvre la porte à une législation
sur l'aide activa mourir et que moi
quand je lis votre rapport je lis c'est
pas pour demain donc dites-moi ce que
vous avez voulu nous dire très très
exactement et puis juste de remarques 1
je pense qu'on est gifère pas en la
matière avec l'expérience personnelle et
je pense que c'est un biais qu'il faut
absolument éviter j'ai je lis à mes
collègues j'étais très déçu par le
dernier examen de la proposition de loi
qu'on aille au Sénat notre collègue
Marie-Pierre la Gontrie que mes
collègues de mon groupe politique ont
tous voté moi je me suis abstenu
parce que je trouve que le débat était
beaucoup trop justement porté sur des
expériences personnelles par contre
répondez pas à une question fondamentale
et je l'ai dit à Marie-Pierre
à la question fondamentale pour moi qui
a rappelé Régis Aubry qui est
le suicide assisté versus leuthanasie
parce que ça pose la question une
question fondamentale c'est le rôle des
soignants
qu'est-ce qu'on accepte que les
soignants fassent
voilà est-ce qu'on accepte que d'une
façon ou d'une autre les soignants
participent directement
à un processus d'administration de la
mort et cette interrogation à la
traversée les mouvements de défense de
droit de l'homme depuis des décennies
donc dans ce qu'était dans d'autres pays
voilà
l'implication des soignants dans des
process liés à la mort et ça
indépendamment du principe d'autonomie
je veux dire une toute société
fonctionne par une répartition des rôles
et par des délimitations qui sont
compréhensibles par chacun
au nom du principe d'automonomie faire
qu'un citoyen puisse accéder au suicide
assisté est une question faire en sorte
donner à des soignants le droit ou la
possibilité de participer à ces
processus c'est une autre question et
une loi qui ne porte pas cette
différence là c'est une mauvaise loi qui
sera inapplicable
peut-être passer à ces questions pour
compléter ce que dit Bernard Chaumier
l'ordre des médecins et concernés si on
parle de la place des soignants entre
autres les médecins travaillent sur le
sujet et on les entendra en commission
puisque le président de l'Ordre m'a dit
qu'il rendrait un avis plutôt début
novembre après avoir consulté l'ensemble
des conseils départementaux de l'ordre
de l'ordre des médecins
on va peut-être déjà répondre à ces
questions ensuite nous aurons deux
autres sénateurs qui se sont inscrits
qui commencent
facteur objectif ou subjectif j'allais
dire les deux
sur les facteurs objectifs et moi je
tiens à le dire
la loi de 2016
ne couvre pas tous les sujets
que nous abordons que nous abordons dans
cette avis mais que nous avions abordé
et régissent à jouer un rôle dans le
précédent à vie
on avait abordé à travers situation
exceptionnelle
c'est vrai que dans le précédent avis le
CCNE ne demandez pas de légiférer mais
avait posé ce sujet de situation
exceptionnelle
alors il y a un facteur objectif facteur
objectif c'est que la sédation profonde
à court terme
ne fonctionne pas médicalement lorsque
le pronostic vital n'est pas engagé à
court terme mais un moyen terme
c'est un sujet je crois qu'il faut qu'on
se le dise là mais les médecins qui sont
autour de
cette table le savent le savent bien
donc il y a véritablement sous réserve
que les soins d'accompagnement existent
il peut y avoir des situations
il peut y avoir des situations où
la question se pose même si la
solidarité existe et c'est dans ce cas
là dans ce cadre là que nous avons
abordé l'aide d'active à mourir alors
je suis pas si on a été meilleur à
l'oral ou à l'être humain mais quand
j'entends ça ça m'inquiète toujours
je sais pas si on n'avait pas été assez
précis à l'écrit et on a complété à
l'oral
sur les soins palliatifs on l'a écrit
et nous trois je crois nous l'avons
appelé il peut y avoir tous les plans
financiers ils sont utiles
mais c'est pas uniquement les plans
financiers annoncés par un ministre qui
régleront ce problème de soin
d'accompagnement il faut y compris dans
la communauté médicale une petite
révolution
pour que ces soins d'accompagnement
figurent dans le processus de soins
d'impatient lorsque il y a un diagnostic
sur tel ou tel maladie c'est ça qu'il
faut faire quoi pourquoi il y a pas
d'équipe de recherche à une cerne
pourquoi il y a pas de PPA sur ces
sujets pourquoi
ces soins ne figurent pas au sein de au
sein de l'hôpital mais parfois ailleurs
alors
sur ces sujets il faut toujours nuancer
moi j'ai vu des cas à Toulouse par
exemple en soins de cancérologie ou
les soins d'accompagnement les soins
palliatifs sont fixés dès le début du
traitement et non pas comme dans la
plupart des cas des soins qui des soins
qui interviennent quelques jours c'est
pour ça que le mot palliatifs
donc voilà alors ça nécessite pas une
loi ça mais il faut véritablement que
s'il législateur décide d'aborder à
nouveau sujet de point de vue
réglementaire et
à travers des actes très concrètement
que sur l'Agence nationale de la
recherche la NR il y a des programmes
fléchés sur sur ces soins
d'accompagnement d'autres pays le font
qu'il y ait au niveau de la Conférence
des Présidents d'Universités des
instructions faites pour nommer des
paysph dans un certain nombre de
s'exercice ça les actes alors concernant
l'aide active à mourir je crois qu'on a
été très clair d'une part on a dit s'il
législateur décide et comme la rappeler
Régis on envisage deux cas
c'est l'assistance
au suicide et là nous mettons
très clairement
le cadre dans lequel on doit pas
sortir c'est à dire la recherche du
consentement à travers une autonomie
exprimée par la personne et ça je crois
qu'on exprime très clairement mais on a
voulu et c'est pour ça qu'on était
jusqu'au bout
qu'une personne autonome
psychologiquement
qui fait cette demande mais qu'il
physiquement n'a pas la possibilité de
faire l'acte on a voulu aborder ce sujet
en abordant ce sujet
on aborde le tanalie et là
le groupe de travail et du comité
plénier n'a pas voulu trancher sur ce
sujet il a laissé de législateur en
disant il y a deux possibilités la
possibilité la solution actuelle c'est à
dire qu'à un moment dans des conditions
particulières le médecin prend la
responsabilité sous le contrôle d'un
juge
ou la deuxième solution c'est de lever
c'est interdite donner la mort et
aborder le sujet l'euthanasie c'est pas
trahir une délibération pas de contrôle
du président que
large majorité que nous avons eu pour
cet avis au sein de cette large majorité
les avis étaient très partagés sur ce
sujet précis on n'est pas à là pour nous
rédiger un projet ou une proposition de
loi c'est là pour mettre des sujets des
sujets sur la table plus concrètement
possible
peut-être un complément de réponse
enfin si on dispose de plusieurs jours
là pour débattre on engage le débat sur
la question de l'autonomie et de la
dignité si vous voulez parce que ce sont
des sujets mais vous avez raison dans ce
que vous pointez monsieur le sénateur
c'est sûr que avoir une vision assez
absolutiste de l'autonomie n'est pas
adaptée
[Musique]
plus on est malade
moi on se connaît plus on se surprend
plus il est difficile d'exercer son
autonomie et plus on a besoin pour
exercer son autonomie d'autrui ce qui
peut paraître un paradoxe mais c'est en
particulier comme cela qu'on peut
définir la relation de confiance qu'on
peut avoir avec des des malades
c'est-à-dire qu'on a besoin de cette
dualité pour que la personne chemine etc
vous disiez que il y a beaucoup de
demandes qui changent alors là on a
maintenant
effectivement des travaux qui avaient
été publiés
par la situationnale des études
démographiques qui ont fait l'objet
maintenant de travaux plus qualitatifs
qui montrent que plus on s'approche de
la fin de son existence plus souvent on
change d'avis donc c'est difficile de
s'arrêter sur un navire à un moment un
autre mais ce qui serait grave également
ça serait de nier l'existence d'une
autonomie à la personne au seul motif
qu'elle est gravement malade je pense
réellement qu'on ne peut pas nier le
fait que certaines personnes et
particulièrement dans ce champ que nous
avons dont nous avons parlé qui n'est
pas celui qui était couvert par le qui
est couvert par la loi léonétique laisse
de 2016
nous avons des personnes qui cheminent
pendant des semaines et des mois
qui dont la demande peut être considérée
comme l'expression de leur volonté parce
que cette demande est élaborée qu'elle
est discutée qu'elle a effectivement
quel est le fruit d'une cheminement on
ne peut pas le nier parce que je pense
qu'il y aurait quelque chose
d'irrespectueux d'indigne à penser que
au seul motif que la personne est à la
fin de son existence elle ne peut plus
avoir d'autonomie qu'on ne peut plus lui
conférer une autonomie c'est très
compliqué ça veut dire qu'il faut un
travail à la classe assistée sur la
notion d'accompagnement on le dit dans
cet avis on l'a dit dans d'autres avis
ce qui ressort de nos réflexions c'est
que tout ce travail d'accompagnement ce
travail d'écoute c'est travail d'aide au
cheminement c'est un travail pour les
soignants qui doit être valorisé il ne
l'est pas suffisamment aujourd'hui il ne
l'est pas on valorise avec les
dispositifs en cours comme la
tarification l'activité on valorise
beaucoup plus l'acte technique mais
l'acte relationnel l'acte humain dans
son expression
profonde n'est pas suffisamment
valorisée et je pense que il y aurait un
risque à ne pas c'est ce que nous disons
dans cet avis nous l'avons dit
probablement pas suffisamment clairement
mais il y aurait un risque à se tourner
que vers cette question de l'évolution
du droit sans se tourner vers cette
question de la nécessité de développer
une vraie
culture de l'accompagnement qu'on
appelle une culture palliative on peut
changer les mots mais c'est le sens qui
compte de mon point de vue quant à la
question de la et de mon point de vue
la question n'est donc la question
prioritaire ne demande point de vue pas
celle de l'évolution du droit mais celle
de l'orientation des politiques dans le
domaine de la santé
considérons-nous
que dans notre pays
l'accompagnement des personnes en
situation de vulnérabilité
indépendamment soit un palliatif
vieillissement je m'excusais ce mais je
parle bien de personnes en situation de
vulnérabilité est-ce que nous
considérons que dans notre pays nous
avons un devoir de de solidarité et donc
d'accompagnement de ces personnes si oui
à ce moment-là nous pouvons bien entendu
analyser des réalités qui comme nous
l'avons dit existent quoi qu'on
veut le dire donc c'est pour moi
extrêmement important que nous
réfléchissions au-delà de la question
stricto-sensuit de la fin de vie sur
l'accompagnement des personnes en
situation de vulnérabilité je crois
d'ailleurs que le débat public qui doit
être un prisme au travers duquel on voit
notre rapport à la question de la
vulnérabilité à la question de la
solidarité je fais partie de ceux qui
pensent que nous
nous avons
nous faisons société parce que nous
faisons solidarité c'est la raison
d'être la solidarité vis-à-vis des
personnes en situation de vulnérabilité
de ce qui fait le ciment de la société
donc évidemment vous voyez où est mon
orientation mon souhait
pour terminer Alain sur cette question
de la
terminologie et de la dignité je préfère
parler de dignité
comme le faisait Robert Badinter si je
peux me référer à lui pour les personnes
qui sont en vie quelle que soit les
personnes et quel que soit leur vie quel
que soit leur elles sont dignes il y a
une forme ontologique à la au sens de la
dignité je leur rapproche plus cette
question de la dignité à la question de
la vie qu'à la question de la mort ou du
mourir ça m'apparaît un débat sans fin
si on veut ressortir ou exhumer cette
question de la de la terminologie mourir
dans la dignité entre guillemets je
préférerais qu'on réfléchisse à vivre
dans la dignité
on a pas retenu dans notre avis c'est
clair
volontairement nous ne sommes pas allés
sur ce terrain
encore une alors encore quelque chose
qui demandera 3 jours de la liberté
c'est encore autre chose que l'autonomie
oui oui oui vous avez raison on emploie
ces mots mais nous en sommes tenu au mot
que nous avons utilisé l'autonomie en la
en la en la nuit ensemble comme je viens
d'essayer de le faire et la solidarité
ça nous a paraissait plus important que
d'employer les mots de dignité de
liberté qui sont des mots-valises et
qu'on peut utiliser dans un sens ou dans
l'autre
[Musique]
d'abord un sachet que le
CCNE dans son ensemble se rend compte de
l'extrême complicité de complexité de ce
sujet
il se il se veut comme une boussole cet
avis se veut comme une boussole pour
comme un processus de démarrage d'une
grande discussion
tout ce qu'on écrit sur ce sujet la main
tremble la Matran parce qu'on touche à
quelque chose de d'extrêmement
fondamental vous en êtes tous conscience
à l'inverse d'autres pays autour de nous
de civilisation de culture certes
différentes mais parfois assez proche
ont su doucement évoluer ou sont en
train d'évoluer donc il est aussi assez
logique que la question se pose en
France
répondre à la question le CCNE avait un
avis différent il y a 7 ou 8 ans
avait un avis d'abord peut-être pas si
différent parce que j'ai en tête et vous
étiez membre du CCNE à cette période
madame la sénatrice dans la vie 129 où
nous avions juste après
juste après
les états généraux de la bioéthique
d'avion est déjà évoqué certaines
situations très particulières qui
pouvait exister
et puis je dirais même que j'irai plus
loin c'est-à-dire que est-ce que le CCNE
est là pour tenir
quoi qu'il en coûte un certain nombre de
valeurs qui est le même ce contredisent
on l'a bien vu entre autonomie
liberté
sans se très global de la réponse
sociétale
ou est-ce qu'il est là aussi pour tenir
compte des évolutions qui existent dans
notre société
à CCNE qui n'évoluerait pas je dirais
sur un certain nombre de questions alors
même que les questions se sont en train
de se poser de façon différente
serait bien sûr serait toujours là mais
somme toute pourquoi faire
et très clairement ça a été indiqué ce
qui a évolué et vous en avez conscience
enfin moi je suis un vieux médecin
il y a j'ai connu l'évolution des soins
palliatifs en France on est toujours en
train de pleurer tous mais ça a
énormément évolué énormément évolué vous
rendez pas compte cette question était
et sur la table il y a eu d'énormes
progrès de fait à la fois chez les pas
suffisamment il faut qu'on continue
d'évoluer mais donc un ça évolué et deux
la médecine et législat très bien
rappelée nous met maintenant dans des
conditions dans certaines conditions
très particulières quand vous êtes en
cinquième sixième ligne de
chimiothérapie pour une femme avec un
cancer de l'ovaire qui est en stade 4
où on peut s'interroger sur remettre
encore une sixième ligne et soit
est-ce que la médecine dans une certaine
mesure ne conduit pas dans certaines
circonstances à des situations très
complexes en cancérologie c'est en train
également de se produire on a eu un
progrès extraordinaire avec les
minothérapies vous le savez à côté de à
côté des chimiots et inversement on est
en train de transformer maintenant avec
une série de succès mais aussi de
d'évolution avec une série de patients
qui rentrent dans des états de
chronicité et là aussi de troisième
quatrième cinquième ligne
et ça n'existait pas il y a 10 ans
donc notre monde est en train de changer
est-ce que le CCNE doit par principe ne
pas évoluer ou est-ce qu'il doit tenir
compte aussi de l'évolution à la fois de
la science et de l'évolution sociétale
alors la deuxième question qu'elle on a
pas répondu je réponds tu as posé une
très bonne question c'est les soignants
c'est alors je l'ai vécu moi j'ai vécu
des choses
l'évolution qui s'est passé au moment du
du sida dans une période extrêmement
difficile des années noires des années
90 94 on a été amené à prendre un
certain nombre de décisions il n'y avait
pas de loi et mes jeunes agrégés m'ont
toujours dit vous avez pris à ce
moment-là un certain nombre de décisions
votre âme est conscience avec les
équipes soignantes en ayant d'ailleurs
interrogé le Conseil de l'Ordre qui ne
répondait pas et sur
et nous on ne peut pas les prendre parce
que vous avez construit ensuite des lois
et maintenant la jeune médecine
et se vit avec les lois c'est comme ça
c'est ce qu'on peut le regretter mais
c'est ou ne pas le regretter mais ils
vivent avec les lois et ils ont ça en
tête alors la question posée n'était pas
celle-là c'était de dire est-ce qu'il
n'y a pas une contradiction à demander
au médecin de sauver de la mort et de
donner la mort bien sûr qu'il y a une
contradiction majeure et tu le sais
parfaitement
c'est pour il sait bien pour ça que
dans les modèles entre guillemets et il
faut bien distinguer et régisse la très
bien fait de distinguer ce qui est
l'aide l'assistance entre guillemets par
rapport à l'euthanasie et si je regarde
le modèle Suisse par exemple il y a bien
une décision médicale collégiale de
pouvoir fournir le médicament et le
médicament est fourni par une par une
association et vous le savez qui qui
fait qui fait une grande partie de du
job en Suisse là dessus bon mais ça
existe également en Oregon c'est les
modèles sont un peu différents en
Belgique et et dans d'autres pays et en
Hollande en particulier
alors il y aura sûrement à devoir de
réserve une Conseil de l'Ordre là déjà
l'a déjà souligné et bien sûr c'est
cette question va se poser la vraie
question qui a derrière c'est est-ce que
compte tenu du changement que 90% des
décès ont lieu maintenant dans un milieu
médicalisé est-ce qu'on reste finalement
avec
l'ensemble des décisions qui restent
entre les mains des médecins
ou est-ce que on laisse une partie de
ces décisions entre les mains de
l'individu et que si les médecins en
effet pour des raisons diverses ne
souhaitent pas participer à cette
décision ils ont bien sûr un devoir de
réserve qui est parfaitement jouable et
qu'on a et qu'on a déjà exercé dans
d'autres conditions vous le savez
c'est un problème essentiel l'Espagne il
y a 3 ans a construit une loi
qui est passée qui est passé qui a été
voté dans le sens un peu rapide sans
écouter son prendre le temps de discuter
avec les équipes soignantes et cette loi
est bloquée
elle n'est pas appliquée parce que les
équipes soignantes ne souhaitent pas une
valent pas l'appliquer donc en effet un
des très gros risques d'évolution
possible c'est si on ne prend pas le
temps de discuter avec l'ensemble des
équipes soignantes et c'est pour ça que
l'enquête du Conseil de l'Ordre est
intéressante j'entends par équipe
soignante non seulement les médecins
mais les aides-soignantes
et vous verrez vous écouterez
probablement l'ensemble et vous verrez
qu'il y a parfois de grosses nuances et
que la fin de vie appartient aussi bien
aux aides-soignantes comme médecin et
deuxièmement que les médecins ne sont
pas seulement les médecins des soins
palliatifs et qui a également tout un
corps médical les cancérologues etc qui
ont accompagné leur patient et dont il
va falloir également écouter la vie sur
le fond
je me permets de renforcer juste une
seconde ce que vient de dire
Jean-François d'être ici
l'implication du professionnel de santé
dans l'assistance officide n'a rien à
voir avec l'implication du profil de
santé dans l'euthanasie je l'ai dit mais
et c'est fondamental à mon avis de faire
cette différence et c'est pourquoi nous
l'avions fait remarquer dans une des
discussions avec la proposition de loi
portée par Monsieur Falorni cette
distinction n'était pas suffisamment
faite et qu'il faut à mon avis
c'est trop important pour que nous
n'ayons cette réalité fondamentale
fondamentalement différente
merci beaucoup alors Olivier Hainaut
ensuite Daniel Chassin victoire Olivier
nous merci madame la Présidente merci
pour vos exposer tout en nuances et
évidemment et que la part de doute qu'on
doit toujours avoir sur ces sujets
lorsqu'on a
auditionné lors du projet de loi de
bioéthique vous aviez monsieur le
professeur delfresci dit cette phrase
terrible j'avais trouvé ça terrible mais
ou combien juste on meurt mal dans notre
pays moi j'avoue que ça m'avait beaucoup
marqué alors il y avait il y a la
question des EHPAD mais il me semble pas
seulement
alors c'est empirique ce que je vais
exprimer là mais je viens aussi d'être
un peu
interpellé par le chiffre de 90% des
personnes meurent à l'hôpital
90% des personnes meurent à l'hôpital et
puis vous avez eu cette phrase notre
mort nous appartient-elle ou
appartient-elle à la société qu'il a
délégué au médecin
j'ai un peu le sentiment que le principe
d'autonomie
monte dans notre société aux dépens du
principe de solidarité mais au fond il y
a pas de temps il y a pas que sur ce
sujet forme de
d'invédusalisme qui correspond aussi à
une forme d'armée américaineisation de
la société de cette culture américaine
qui nous EMBA et nous envahit peu au
prout tout de même bon
et
souvent j'entends les gens qui sont qui
se rapprochent de la mort dire moi je
voudrais mourir chez moi
mais c'est un truc qu'on entend tout le
temps
or de fait c'est loin d'être le cas et
je pense que ça participe à la
croissance de l'angoisse de la mort et
je pense que ça participe aussi à la
montée du principe d'autonomie et donc
ma question mais une manière totalement
empirique sans avoir de
solutions est-ce que c'est inéluctable
cette question de 90% de personnes qui
meurent à l'hôpital est-ce qu'il y a pas
un chemin
pour à la fois mourir dans la dignité et
mourir chez soi voilà la question qui
que je me pose sous est très fréquemment
de manière assez empirique je vous
remercie
Daniel Chassain merci madame la
Présidente merci sur le professeur et
merci messieurs pour toutes ces
explications qui ont été données et vous
avez effectivement indiqué qu'il y a des
situations difficiles
tous les âges
qui est cancers les maladies
[Musique]
neurones
des situations rares est-ce que la loi
suffit vous avez répondu que
effectivement il y a des situations où
elle est peut-être pas suffisante mais
je reprendrai à ce qui est dit Olivier
nous aussi
il y a peu de personnes qui meurent à
domicile c'est parce que il y a pas
suffisamment d'accompagnement
d'accompagnement si vous voulez de la
famille
d'accompagnement aussi du médecin ou de
ou de l'infirmière qui aura des
difficultés
lorsque dans les derniers jours
elle sera elle n'aura pas forcément
toutes les trois pas régler ni le
médecin toutes les situations
pense que lorsqu'on est à l'hôpital on
est quand même on peut avoir des drogues
plus beaucoup plus facilement qu'à
domicile mais tout tout est le problème
d'accompagnement et je pense que c'est
pas suffisant parce que on sait que même
si l'immunothérapie a fait beaucoup de
de progrès et heureusement il y a des
guérissons même lorsque on est dans des
stades comme vous l'avez dit très avancé
mais on sait quand même que dans
certains cas malgré les soins on sait
que progressivement ça va s'aggraver et
on n'aura pas de guérison et on va
arriver au moment où on va être en
difficulté et je pense que c'est là où
on n'a pas suffisamment d'accompagnement
qui est qui est qui est qui a commencé
depuis déjà plusieurs mois et c'est
simplement la fin parce que lorsque on
imagine les gens ils auront pas cet avis
si vous voulez de vouloir mourir ou si
on les accompagne d'abord en
psychologiquement mais aussi
au niveau de l'aide à au soulagement
donc moi je pense que c'est là le gros
problème parce que la loi léonieclès a
fait énormément de progrès lorsqu'elle
est appliquée dans des départements
notamment des départements ruraux comme
la Corrèze où il y a des soins
palliatifs qui se déplacent dans les
EHPAD même à domicile et bien notamment
dans les EHPAD on a quand même beaucoup
moins de difficultés et les familles
apprécient bien sûr beaucoup cet
accompagnement mais il sait
s'accompagnement des soins palliatifs et
sur les derniers jours lorsqu'on leur
faire appel ou les les dernières
semaines je pense qu'il faudrait qu'il
soit pris en amont mais est-ce qu'on
doit changer une loi ou simplement
l'adapter parce que en fait dans
certains départements ça n'existe pas
est-ce qu'il faut pas renforcer cette
loi dans le sens de l'accompagnement
c'est à dire renforcer en fait les soins
palliatifs et intégrés comme vous l'avez
dit les autres médecins qui
interviennent en amont notamment
l'équipe avec l'infirmière et
l'aide-soignante
victoire jasmin oui merci madame la
Présidente merci
aux différents intervenants
j'apprécie le débat le débat que nous
avons ici un débat où on parle quand
même de solidarité de dignité et on
parle également de souffrance des
soignants pourtant je n'arrive toujours
pas à comprendre comment a-t-on pu
banaliser l'administration du Rivotril
il y a quelques mois on n'a pas tenu
compte de tout cela voilà merci
merci
moi je vais avant de passer la question
cette notion de mourir dans la dignité
moi m'a toujours un peu je l'ai dit à
chaque fois qu'il y avait les débats
se dire on a tous dans nos entourage
connu des gens qui étaient en fin de vie
avec parfois en effet une fin de vie qui
n'était pas celle qu'il souhaitait et
qu'on souhaitait pour eux mais jamais
aucun moment on a jugé qu'ils étaient
indignes la dignité elle est jusqu'au
dernier souffle et le nom de cette
association en train de mourir d'un
unité moi me perturbe complètement un
côté que que je trouve un peu choquant
même donc ça c'est ça bon ce qui s'est
passé en Belgique avec cette jeune femme
qui
était des gros en grande souffrance
après après des attentats quel est votre
regard en effet sur cette situation et
puis il y avait des articles bon
peut-être comme tous les articles de
journaux du week-end peut-être un peu
réducteur mais qui disait que des
mutuelles se positionnaient aussi et ça
ça incite un peu et ça revient la
question posée Corinne Humbert est-ce
que finalement c'est pas aussi une
solution pour développer des soins
palliatifs
alors c'est peut-être un peu loin
derrière un côté économique derrière je
n'irai pas jusque là parce que ce serait
sûrement caricatural mais néanmoins ça
fait ça fait poser beaucoup de questions
sur la question alors sur la question on
meurt mal en France on enlève pas
beaucoup discuté avec
Jean-François je pense que nous nous
reprendrions pas vraiment cette
expression aujourd'hui parce que si on
la retourne il faut qu'on il faut qu'on
se dise qu'est-ce que ce serait bien
mourir et nous ne savons pas répondre à
cette question j'ai une croix même qu'il
serait un peu hasardeuse d'imaginer que
l'on puisse mourir heureux enfin
excusez-moi mais je pense que c'est une
épreuve ça fait partie de ces épreuves
de la vie c'est pas la seule d'ailleurs
qui ne peut pas être autrement que
douloureuse quand on disait cela on le
disait pour dire en réalité souligner
l'insuffisance des moyens dont on a
parlé ici vous évoquiez les uns et les
autres la question du domicile et en
particulier
parce que on devrait aussi distinguer
contenu de ce qu'on vient de dire aussi
du fait que la fin de vie le temps de la
fin de vie est en train d'augmenter de
façon considérable on devrait distinguer
la question du lieu de la fin de vie
d'éventuellement du lieu du mourir et
c'est bien du lieu de la fin de vie
qu'il s'agit quand les gens disent
j'aimerais autant pas finir à l'hôpital
parce que ça pourrait être une longue
période
et quoi qu'il en soit si le domicile est
plébiscité dans dans tous les travaux
qui ont été publiés sur ce point de vue
là on voit bien qu'il est quand même
difficile de permettre la fin de
l'existence au domicile c'est difficile
parce que notre société totalement
changé en 50 ans les la possibilité de
garder à domicile quelqu'un qui pendant
des semaines des mois et dépendant
douloureux etc il y a plus de familles
multigénération fait d'habitat
multigénérationnel disons pratiquement
disparu c'est déjà une explication puis
une explication extrêmement importante
il se trouve que j'ai dirigé
l'Observatoire national de la fin de vie
nous avions beaucoup travaillé sur cette
question il y a des professionnels qui
en France par rapport à d'autres pays ne
sont pas assez valorisés Jean-François
parler des aides-soignantes mais je
parlerai des aides à domicile voilà une
profession
insuffisamment formée insuffisant
rémunéré insuffisant reconnu qu'on
envoie
il y a quelques années qui montraient
que lorsqu'on contraint des personnes à
aller là où elles ne souhaitent pas
aller dans certains états il s'agit pas
d'une critique des EHPAD il s'agit de
d'une critique de l'absence
l'insuffisance des alternatives et bien
elle ne peuvent pas bien finir leur
existence certaines choisissent le
suicide c'est aussi pour ça que nous
sommes très vigilants à faire coexister
notre réflexion sur l'évolution du droit
à l'obligation d'avoir des politiques
d'accompagnement des vulnérabilités
et puis justement par rapport à votre
question sur le sur le rivotril
[Musique]
il y a eu vous vous rappelez peut-être
que pendant la première vague je parle
sur ton contrôle Jean-François et il y a
eu face à une pénurie du midazolam qui
est un médicament que nous utilisons
pour la sédation profonde et continue
jusqu'au décès face à une pénurie qui
était liée à une utilisation massive
dans les services de réanimation il y a
eu une insuffisance de disponibilité de
ce médicament mis d'azolam et il y avait
en même temps à ce moment là je parle de
la première vague des situations de fin
de vie à domicile ou dans les EHPAD qui
nécessitaient que nous ayons parfois
recours à un médicament pour endormir
des personnes à défaut du médiasolam il
y a eu une autorisation temporaire
d'accès aux
rivotril qui est un autre médicament
mais ça n'est pas le médicament le plus
adapté puisque au contraire à la Haute
Autorité de Santé avait démontré que ce
n'était pas celui-ci qu'il fallait
auquel il fallait mais un autre mais
maintenant que cette pénurie n'a plus
lieu il n'y a plus d'utilisation et
d'indications à utiliser du Rivotril
juste un mot
au-delà de la vie
je pense que ce soit législateur que ce
soit
l'exécutif ou que ça soit des organismes
qui réfléchissent sur ce sujet
c'est vrai j'en prends soin de d'être
ici a raison
que de progrès franchit sur ses soins
dit palliatifs
mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui il y a une
petite révolution encore à faire sur ce
sujet que j'appelle soin
d'accompagnement
si on prend pas un certain nombre de
mesures
entendra un rond pendant longtemps je
prends un seul exemple la T2A
la T2A ça a été un progrès à l'hôpital
d'introduire ce mode de financement par
rapport aux dotations de fonctionnement
mais je suis convaincu que vous-même
vous l'exécutif auront à se poser la
question est-ce que c'est soit un
accompagnement doivent pas sortir de tes
deux hommes
je pense que ce sujet il est devant nous
et je pense que
prendre une telle décision
aurait beaucoup plus d'efficacité que
tous ces plantes sont un palliatifs
quand quel que soit les gouvernements on
a mis les donc c'est un sujet qui est
devant nous sur la mobilité parce que
c'est ça cette question de pas mourir
pas vouloir mourir à l'hôpital
il y a des choses concrètes vous le
connaissez par cœur les EHPAD
87 ans et demi
le vendredi à 18h
il n'y a plus d'infirmière
le médecin coordinateur n'est plus là
donc il y a de moins de problèmes aux
urgences
tous les chiffres tous les connaît tous
les connaissances donc c'est sur ces
sujets là on doit peser bien un dernier
sujet
je crois que
on n'a pas fini de réfléchir à cette
notion par rapport à ce que disent
Jean-François et régis par rapport aux
progrès scientifiques et c'est un sujet
peut-être qu'on aura abordé nous aussi
CCE sur cette notion d'obstination
déraisonnable
est-ce qu'on a été au bout de la
réflexion je pense que c'est sûrement un
sujet pour nous c'est celle mais pour
vous législateur sur lequel il faudra il
faudra à nouveau réfléchir
oui madame la Présidente moi je voudrais
vous remercier messieurs en tout cas de
ce rapport qui est riche et
particulièrement instructif sur sur un
sujet compliqué il est vrai j'ai une
question et une remarque ma question
pensez-vous que que nous avons les
moyens et je pense qu'il c'est un
passage obligé pour moi je voudrais voir
votre avis de pouvoir évaluer d'être en
capacité d'évaluer cette loi de 2016
dans toutes ses composantes avant
peut-être d'élucubrer et d'aller plus
loin sur ce sujet je voudrais avoir
votre avis là-dessus en tout cas moi
j'en suis personnellement convaincu et
puis je voudrais insister sur cette idée
que vous avez développé mais à mon avis
pas suffisamment que la finitude n'est
pas un échec et je crois qu'on est
encore malheureusement
trop enclin à penser aujourd'hui dans
notre société mais pas qu'en France que
la finitude est un échec je vous
remercie
sur l'évaluation de la loi classe on
touche là du doigt
le fait que nous avons une culture assez
faible en France de l'évaluation des
politiques publiques
c'est
à la fois bon fait assez peu de choses
disons-le que dans le domaine de la
santé qu'on connaît le mieux mais
ailleurs aussi me semble-t-il
c'est en plus fait souvent par des
cabinets d'audits extérieure
il y a assez peu de demandes à
l'université qui où il y aurait d'une
expertise qui pourrait qui pourrait
aider entre guillemets à une forme
d'évaluation des politiques publiques
et il n'y a pas de à ce jour en tout cas
nous l'avions demandé
dès le début de de la de la réflexion du
groupe de travail des juin 2021
mais il n'y a pas à ce jour de bonne
évaluation claire au niveau du ministère
de la Santé en tout cas nous ne l'avons
pas
de de cette de la locationnetti alors je
pense qu'il y a une demande qui a été
faite
je crois avec une enquête Cour des
comptes menée par l'Assemblée nationale
et qui est prévu pour avoir une première
forme d'évaluation au mois de mars
si s'il y avait d'ailleurs au passage
s'il y avait pour une loi de s'il avait
une évolution dans la loi et peut-être
qu'il n'y aura pas d'évolution dans la
loi il faut être clair
il serait fondamental à nos yeux que les
parlementaires et les sénateurs au sens
trailers du terme puisse demander dans
le cadre même de la loi qui est une
évaluation de la nouvelle loi dans un
temps donné c'est quelque chose je sais
pas si c'est faisable je ne connais rien
dans dans les pratiques parlementaires
mais mais ça serait ça devrait être
vraiment sur des grandes des grandes
décisions de politique publique c'est ça
ça paraît fondamental
donc la réponse oui on l'aura dans un
délai de je dirais au printemps de 2000
2023 c'est à dire un moment donné où la
convention citoyenne sera en train de se
terminer et où il y aura donc
probablement un ensemble de données qui
vont qui vont être qui vont être qui
vont construire un peu le mécano de nos
connaissances
il y a également probablement une j'ai
compris qu'il y aurait une demande
probablement passant par l'IGAS de
l'Assemblée nationale sur évaluation de
la loi classique
je te laisse répondre pour la suite
c'était la fin de vie n'est pas
n'est pas n'est pas forcément une
enfin de considérons pas la finitude
comme un échec
oui mais vous avez raison quand vous
parlez de cette
cette assimilation littéralement qui est
faite par les médecins en particulier de
la fin de la vie et de la mort comme
étant leur échec il y a quelque chose
qui biaise totalement la possibilité au
contraire d'être dans un cheminement
mais ça rejoint aussi toute une
discussion sur
la nécessité de penser ce qu'on appelle
par ailleurs des niveaux de soins je
disais tout à l'heure ça n'est pas parce
que l'on sait faire que l'on doit faire
on devrait interroger face à la
complexité et de façon très
interdisciplinaire le sens même de ce
que soignait veut dire et de ce que
traiter veut dire et parfois et c'est
probablement la décision qui aujourd'hui
la plus difficile pour un médecin
décidait de ne pas faire avec quelque
chose qui peut être plus bénéfique que
décidé de faire nous en avons beaucoup
parlé de cette question que vous posez
là parce que dans un autre avis en
préparation on voit bien que cette
question
interroge
le sens même de ce que soignait veut
dire et de ce que vivre veut dire et que
en miroir de cette question qui n'est
pas abordée et bien il y a la souffrance
des soignants
quand vous ne savez plus pourquoi vous
vous travaillez quand vous vous posez
plus les bonnes questions vous avez de
mon point de vue une des explications ça
serait assez réducteur de le réduire à
cela mais c'est une explication
importante de la souffrance actuelle
dans le monde du soin et de la santé et
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important de mon point de vue de
développer
probablement dans un autre avis nous
nous en reparlerons mais de développer
non pas simplement une culture du soin
palliatif une culture de la réflexion
éthique
hésiter ne pas être sûr de soi
travailler collectivement
interroger les limites du savoir les
limites de la ville les limites du sens
et bien si ceci peut s'apprendre
mais ceci s'éprouve de façon il faut
valoriser le travail en équipe il faut
valoriser le temps nous faisons le
constat dans d'autres travaux que nous
menons que parfois les temps des
personnes malades et les familles ne
croisent plus les temps des soignants
c'est quelque chose qui est dramatique
ça de mon point de vue
pour être peut-être plus clair juste
deux minutes
donc pour être clair parce que je viens
de dire peut-être dans un prochain
et je mets clairement vous expliquer
nous sortirons un prochain avis
probablement d'ici la fin octobre sur
enjeux éthique et quelle valeur pour la
reconstruction du système de soins et
qui pose vraiment au cœur de cet avis la
notion que la notion du temps et la
notion du temps du soignant et la notion
du temps du soignant pour les familles
et la notion du temps pour les patients
est un élément clé de cette
reconstruction et que c'est une valeur
fondamentale qui a été qui a été
beaucoup négligée au cours des dernières
années donc voilà c'était pour clarifier
ce que tu venais de dire donc ce qui
veut dire que nous serons prochainement
une nouvelle audition
pour pour il faut nous présenter cet
avis car en effet majeur merci beaucoup
pour cette présentation et à bientôt à
bientôt merci beaucoup donc rendez-vous
demain matin 9h30 en commission
la CNAF voilà